-Our first guest tonight is
a talented actress you know from
films such as "21 Bridges,"
"American Woman"
and "Factory Girl."
She stars in
"Anatomy of a Scandal,"
which begins streaming
April 15th on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-You're not going to be
springing any surprises on us,
are you, Sophie?
-Such as?
-Well, announcing
that you're leaving,
putting on your side
of the story.
-Do you need to ask?
-Of course I do.
-Of course she's not leaving.
I'm sorry, darling,
I didn't mean to.
-Of course I'm not leaving.
We've been married for 12 years.
We share two children.
Why would I throw all that away
over a stupid mistake?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Sienna Miller,
everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is so lovely to see you
in person again.
-Thank you. So nice to see
everybody in person again.
-I know, isn't it wonderful
to be in front of people
and everything?
-A live human
with a live audience.
-A live audience.
It's very nice.
I do want to follow up from
the last time you were here.
You were talking about -- You
wanted to find the sort of work
that maybe your daughter
could engage in.
Because you do a lot of sort of
R-rated adult fare.
-This is not that.
-No, this is not a show
for kids.
-Nope. No.
Because you don't do,
you know, again,
these are wonderful,
but like, you know, adult fare.
Does your daughter even --
What does she think you do?
I mean, she must know
you're an actor.
-You know, she's going to be 10
in July,
so she's seen
a little bit of this.
And we fast-forwarded
the really, highly inappropriate
moments of which
there are a few.
But you know, she actually --
I was doing a play in London
and she said, "Can I watch it?"
and I said, "No."
It was "Cat on a Hot Tin Roof,"
which starts off kind of --
-Yeah, very fun.
-Pretty fun
and then quickly deteriorates
into something else.
And she said, "Can I come?"
and I said, "You can watch
the first 10 minutes,"
and she was in the sound box.
And then I was like, you know,
then my assistant was going to
take her out.
She refused to leave,
and it was a live show.
And she was like, "No, no."
So she's --
Yeah, she stayed and watched.
-She out-thought you
on that one.
-She's outwitting me on every
single -- She's like me.
-It's very smart to be like,
"Yes, I will leave 10 minutes
into your play" and then be
like, "I'm not going."
"And I'm going to make
a fair amount of noise."
-Exactly. And there's nothing
you can do about it.
Then the following day,
she was very respectful
and let me sleep in, which
doesn't often happen
because she's like,
"Mum's an actor."
That lasted an hour.
-Oh, that's very sweet. Yeah.
-One day. One day of respect.
-Even if you get an hour,
that's something.
-I know.
-Your daughter, Marlowe,
which is a beautiful name.
You said she's almost 10.
Do you see yourself in her now?
I mean, that's an age
where you can tell.
-She's like me 2.0.
I mean, she's like -- I think
I had all of what she expresses
contained inside and just didn't
have the courage to let it out.
-Oh, that must be fun to see.
-She's extra.
I mean, she is like
fully out there.
I mean, kids today,
you've got three now.
-Yes.
-It's intense.
And girls in New York City,
she's like, "No, no, no."
You know?
-It is really amazing growing --
like, raising kids in New York.
-Yeah.
-Because I grew up
in the suburbs.
We walked through Washington
Square Park the other day,
and my 4-year-old
was the weirdest person
in Washington Square Park.
-That's really impressive.
-Like, loudly weird.
-Wow.
-He was pulling -- He got out of
the stroller and pulled it
behind him and kept telling
people he was a UPS guy.
[ Laughter ]
-I love him.
-And you can tell, like,
even, like, people
in Washington Square Park
who are not doing well.
-Yes, that's an understatement.
-And they were like, "This guy
has got some work to do."
-Wow. Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I mean,
when I was growing up,
I was just saying sorry
the whole time.
It's very English to do that.
-Yes.
-She does not have that problem.
-Oh, that's nice, though.
Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I'll use that as a transition.
This show is a very --
So this is a --
This is a very British show
as well.
It's based on a scandal.
-Yes.
-And I will say,
I think British scandals
are my favorite of the scandals.
-I mean, we do scandal well.
Don't we?
-You do scandal very well.
Because there's a lot of
pretending it isn't a scandal.
Like, that clip was very good.
-Oh, sweeping it under the rug.
-Yes.
-Like, "What scandal?
What are you talking about?"
-"We'll be fine."
[ Laughter ]
-What, what, what, what?
No, it quickly deteriorates into
full-blown, like,
undeniable scandal.
You know, it's David E. Kelley
and Melissa James Gibson.
They did "The Undoing"
and "Big Little Lies."
And it's that format.
And they're so good at it.
-Yeah.
-I love those.
-So this is actually tricky
because I love "The Undoing."
But the British guy, Hugh Grant
in that, he was suspicious
the whole time
because he was British.
-Yes. Yes.
-But in this one, everybody's
British, so you really
don't know who to trust.
[ Laughter ]
-So true.
Never trust the British men.
-Yeah. I mean, he was --
From the very beginning, you're
like, "Come on, Hugh Grant."
-It's too much hair to trust.
-Yeah.
-Right, at that age.
-Absolutely.
I mean, he looks too good
to be trusted.
-Yes, exactly.
-This is based on a book.
Had you read the book?
-I did not read the book.
-Okay.
-I read the book after I'd read
the six scripts,
which were so compelling.
-Okay.
-And then, you know, that thing
of an actor
where you have to really
do the research.
All of that was done for me
in the book.
-That's very nice. Yes.
-All of the thoughts --
It was great.
It's a brilliant book.
-Do you usually read
a thriller like that?
Is that a kind of book
you turn to?
-I love them, and I will take
them on a holiday,
but I always get guilt that I
haven't read the classics,
so I kind of punish myself
with my reading.
Like, "Why am I not reading
'Hardy' that I have not read
instead of this really
compelling, addictive one?"
-This is very noble.
So you're still --
-I mean, it takes me like
10 years.
I've just finished
"War and Peace" like eight --
-You did "War and Peace"?
-I did it.
-Alright. So this is fascinating
to me because I --
So, I read "War and Peace."
-Don't ask me what happened.
-Okay, I won't.
-I understood three words.
But, yes, I read it.
-But that's what I was gonna
say. I read it in college,
but it was a -- The whole course
was "War and Peace."
So we had a professor
that sort of held our hand
through all of it, and I would
say, like, it was a great --
like, having someone walk you
through it,
I'm like,
"This is really great."
But I would also say, one,
I don't remember anything
that happened.
And I can't imagine doing it
alone on your own.
So that's very impressive.
-You know, it was good.
It started in lockdown.
It ended recently.
It's a long book.
-It's a very long book.
-But my God, that Tolstoy can
write a book.
-Oh, you know what?
If you take anything away
from this interview,
"that Tolstoy can write a book."
-Yeah, he's good with words.
-He's not too shabby.
[ Laughter ]
It's a shame. What happened to
him? Is he still working?
-I don't think so.
That's Hollywood for you.
They just -- They find
the hot new thing
and they just move on.
[ Laughter ]
And you got to -- This was a
lockdown show as well, so you --
-Yes. I got to leave
the lockdown to go to work,
which was really, really lucky.
-Yeah.
And you got to be in London as
well, or I guess in England.
Did you shoot in London?
-We shot at Shepperton Studios,
which is outside of London
and around London.
-Okay, great.
-A bit of Manchester.
It was great.
I was so ready to be around
family and home.
And I'd done the first bit
in New York, which was intense.
So I was just ready to go back.
So we had this year.
-And so were you in actual
sort of courthouses
or were they courthouse sets?
-They were sets
because of COVID.
They had to rebuild the
Old Bailey and places like that,
which they did perfectly.
Like, we have this incredible
house.
It was all a set.
I wanted to just, like, forklift
it somewhere else
and live in it forever
because it was so nice.
-I mean, the Old Bailey always,
you know, it seems so historic.
Was that something when you grew
up in London,
did you, like, go there
on field trips?
Is that like a thing you do
as a young --
-Nope. No. No.
-No?
-We'd go to like the farm or --
[ Laughter ]
You know, I wish we did.
You can actually go and sit in
on real trials,
which I've always --
I've meant to do,
but it's one of those things
that I've never done.
-Well, you're too busy
reading Tolstoy.
-Exactly, Seth. Yes.
-You've got a lot of big things
going on.
-Yes, I'm a busy lady.
Yes, exactly.
-Well, it is always --
Congratulations on the show.
-Thank you.
-It's wonderful.
And it's always so wonderful
to see you.
Thanks so much for being here,
Sienna.
-Thanks for having me.
-Sienna Miller, everybody.
"Anatomy of a Scandal" begins
streaming April 15th on Netflix.